we've been sort of trying to quantify
the cognitive dissonance and the
ideological commitment to Donald Trump
that's present among some Republicans
and we've got some new polling data that
suggests it's even worse than we thought
Donald Trump has successfully convinced
some trumpets that voter fraud not voter
suppression is a major problem and about
half of Republicans say that they would
actually be in favor of postponing the
2020 presidential election until the
country presumably under the leadership
of Donald Trump could fix the
non-existent problems that Donald Trump
has identified this is based on a sample
of 650 Republicans it's it's amazing
that this is the reality in the United
States a sample of 650 Republicans or
Republican leaners the sample was
weighted to match the Republican Party
at large in terms of sex age race in
education they were initially asked some
some preliminary questions and then
respondents were asked did Donald Trump
win the popular vote did millions of
undocumented immigrants vote illegally
how often does a voter fraud actually
occur about half of Republicans believe
that Donald Trump won the popular vote
of course he lost by pretty significant
margin for a presidential election 2.9
million votes about two percentage point
lows to three million votes and that's
similar to other polls that have asked
Republicans the same question not an
outlier in that sense 68 percent of
Republicans do believe that millions of
illegal immigrants voted illegally that
is nearly three out of four more than
two-thirds of Republicans believe the
idea that a whole bunch millions of
illegal immigrants voted 73% of
Republicans believe that voter fraud
happens somewhat are very often even
though we have anecdotally what a dozen
cases over the last billion plus ballots
that have been cast and then the survey
asked two questions about postponing the
2020 election if Donald Trump were to
announce that the 2020 presidential
election should be postponed until the
country can make sure that only eligible
American citizens can vote would you
support postponing the election 52% of
Republicans say if Trump wants to do it
they would support
delaying the 2020 election the thing is
we already are concerned that we're
heading towards the constitutional
crisis that's when one branch of powers
can't be checked by the other two and
when shrimp floats the idea of firing
Jeff Sessions or in Robert mola Robert
Muller there's a fear that he'll be able
to get away with it and that Congress
can't effectively check him if this was
to happen where he postponed the 2020
election for his own benefit the epitome
that would be the end but luckily just
his supporters wanting that to happen
isn't going to make it actually happen
hopefully not yeah and also respondents
were asked what if Donald Trump and
Republicans in Congress were united in
saying that the 2020 President
presidential election should be delayed
then it goes up to 56% of Republicans
saying yeah I I think if Trump and and
congressional Republicans said we have
to delay the election we would be in
favor of delaying the election and
obviously the more you believe Trump's
lies about the popular vote and illegal
voters the more likely you are to
support this hypothetical postponement
of the election this is what lunatic
right-wingers said Obama was going to do
remember there was no evidence Obama was
going to declare martial law and push
off the election to make himself Emperor
King Obama whatever no evidence that
that was going to happen and you still
had lunatic right-wingers saying Obama
is not going to got not going to
relinquish power you now actually have
Trump falsely talking about voter fraud
and these individuals basically it's a
50/50 shot say if Trump wanted to
postpone the election because of the
voter fraud he alleges exists I would be
in favor of that
you know after 9/11 New York City Mayor
Rudy Giuliani wanted to push his term
into the following year into 2002 and
delay the transition of power to deal
with 9/11 and the cleanup and everything
else and maybe you could think that's a
valid reason if Trump you know with his
idea of floating all these distractions
perhaps nor with worth North Korea uses
that as an excuse for keeping his own
power for an extra few months or years
do you think that would work
no right I mean no who would've loved
who would really allow that like even if
half of Republicans want that and Trump
Trump start saying listen I believe that
there is a conspiracy
to get me out of power until I am sure
that we will have a fair election we are
not going to have an election to ever
happen I'm on board with you here I
think the Constitution prevents against
that sort of thing
how would Trump even try to justify it
right hey we had major major voter fraud
people huge big lis buses bringing in
Hillary voters I actually won the
popular vote in 2016 did you know that
my generals I consulted with them three
to five million illegals we got to
resolve that problem folks before we can
open the voting just a temporary delay
people believe me very very temporary
tremendously temporary we're very close
to having the most fair election in the
world this will be a level of fairness
in elections the likes of which no
country has ever seen before err ever
but we need a little more time Baron is
working with the Russian as I'm sorry
Baron is working with the IT people
amazing what Baron can do with computers
these days Steve Jobs great computer
great guy overall he knew about nuclear
and very serious things very temporary
election soon okay I think even the
Trump supporters realized that there's a
small chance of this guy actually
winning reelection but you know maybe
I'm speaking too soon because very few
people thought he would actually run and
then win the nomination and for some
debates and then become president who
does anything at this point and and and
the background is always the reality
that that if Trump was Putin's puppet
this is exactly what Putin would want
Trump to be doing right talk about how
core mechanisms of our democracy have
been destabilized we can't even trust
our elections at all we've got to delay
the election not that that would
actually happen but even the attack on
the integrity of our elections through
voter fraud voter suppression is very
real and we'll have a great
investigative piece about that in the
next couple weeks but even attacking the
idea that the elections are legit from
the voter fraud side that benefits other
world leaders who want to sort of
posture geopolitically against or in
contrast to the United States maybe
Trump will pull a Vladimir Putin here
and go back and forth between being
president and Prime Minister Zhao of
course we don't have a prime minister
here but he would find a way Trump could
create that listen folks president only
doesn't make any sense I'm going to run
this like a business and part of that is
being a prime minister to make deals
while presidents Baron trunk or whoever
or Milania Milania
incredible Melania is truly truly
incredible here legally I never worked
here illegally ammonia to see her birth
certificate to see her birth certificate
adore her work authorization from when
she was modeling here yeah I don't
really think this is going to be a
discussion that will be will be a
pressing issue but it is stunning the
degree to which some of these trumpets
have become totally bamboozled by the
Trump thing I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
follow me there today's sponsor is taga
dab the hosting specialist whatever your
hosting needs for your business or
project taga dab can do it dedicated
servers virtual private servers cloud
server solutions colocation custom
server solutions and the big thing at
taga dab is their customer support over
70% of their business comes from repeat
orders and recommendations from existing
customers this is a testament to the
great support that they give their
customers currently rated a nine point
seven out of ten according to the
Trustpilot review system with a growing
number of people interested in moving
their businesses and projects to the
cloud CagA dab currently offers our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers that sign
up gives you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer for
the viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to sign up CAG
adapt calm /t DPS and use the offer code
TDPS
20 during account registration support
our sponsors and support our show in
doing so sign up ta ga da be calm /t DPS
coupon code is P DPS 20